laurel is with us in houston texas to
start off this hour
hi laurel how are you good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so me and my husband are 31 years old
and we're in baby step seven
and we just had our first baby wow
congrats
yes thanks so i was planning on going
back to work
after my three month maternity leave but
now i'm thinking i might want to be a
stay-at-home mom
and i'm kind of nervous about the
decision because
i make over half our household income
and
more importantly i'm worried about
getting back into a career
career after maybe staying at home for
seven to ten years
with all our kids um until they go into
school
so i just wanted to get your thoughts on
is this an okay
financial decision and also do you have
any advice
on getting back into a career after
being out maybe up to 10 years
your home is paid for yes
and you guys make how much each
i make and forty thousand dollars and my
husband makes a hundred thousand dollars
before taxes
what do you do i'm a chemical engineer
okay well i i don't know
a lot about the tactical aspects of what
it takes to be a chemical engineer on a
day in and day out basis
i do grasp the idea that it is chemistry
and a lot of math
and neither of those are going to change
right chemistry's not going to evolve uh
to where you don't even know where you
don't understand the formulas in seven
years
and certainly math and certainly math is
not going to
there may be some discoveries and some
things that there will be
some discoveries and things that um you
know will affect that things
you may keep up with those just by
reading and staying on top of things
but i don't know that you know for
instance if you were a
um a software engineer
seven years from now you would be an
absolute idiot you would have no idea
yeah what's going on
because it will have completely changed
in seven years agreed
agreed but i think your the world that
you're in is much more stable because
it's based on
uh formulas and suppositions is it not
that's true so um it's not a
rapidly evolving completely turning over
set of information
that you would become irrelevant in
seven years and you would in some
industries i mean there's a lot of
things that are moving very very fast
and
in seven years i mean i look back seven
years in broadcasting how much it's
changed you know but uh but you could
you can come back in with that skill set
now
you know you may have a a process to do
that
but you're a hundred percent debt free
he makes a hundred thousand dollars a
year you guys can live on that can't you
yeah so we're confident of that but i
would definitely want to
go back to work at some point so i guess
it just
makes us nervous to have such a big
change but we
could really obviously have a good life
on a hundred thousand dollars
and i don't know why you couldn't take
on a a a lightweight consulting gig ever
so often to keep your toe in the water
that's what i was going to say
especially like the last two years like
mainly with the not with a money goal
but a goal of staying relevant
right um okay
and i was and and i'm not a father so i
mean listen to dave more you listen to
me but i'm i'm also thinking like maybe
you spend the first five years
and then the last two years you start
just inching your way back into
picking up some consulting stuff going
out around it so this way when you're
ready to go full throttle in it you're
already emerged back into
uh any changes that have already been
there but i would say the first you know
few years yeah focus on your kids
you guys have worked so hard to get to
this point
to be able to make these choices yeah
and you're in a position to make the
choices
and here's the thing you will not get
to 84 years old and look back and go oh
darn i didn't maximize
my career yeah you will get to 84
and say oh darn i miss those kids i miss
their childhood i could have stayed home
yeah that's what i'm most scared of yeah
so quit
yeah okay all right thank you that
helped me feel a lot better yeah that's
what we would do at the ramsey house
anyway
because money's only good for one thing
causing the things in your life that you
want to have happen
that's what it's for and that includes
generosity
yeah and the only reason we invest is so
we can cause more things to happen in
our life we're controlling more
variables in our life
and you've done that with baby step
seven way to go
you know what dave i like how you just
said that man
they even got me kind of emotional
because when i heard that i heard her
say man
i wish my parents would have been around
maybe a little bit more i'm grateful
that they did what they had to do
they had to walk yeah and work but
hearing that
she has the opportunity to be more
involved into the younger people's life
that is to me that is more valuable than
making a whole lot of money because
that's a strong investment
given that that's their situation that's
what she's able to number one number two
it's her desire yes where you know we've
got
that's not to put shame on a lady who
chooses to say i want to work
no i know i get i get joy out of being
at home with the kids
when i'm at home but i also like good
joy out of my career yeah
and um and but she just had a baby and
she's like no i'm done
tap out tap out yeah and so that that's
cool so
yeah we don't we don't shame stayed on
moms and we don't shame uh not
stay-at-home moms
absolutely my moms are not that uh but i
do
for me and my future all right i want to
give the chance
the opportunity yes choice yes yeah it's
not a matter of
if they need to work exactly it's do
they want to and it's like hey
it's like if you want to quit whenever
you want to quit quit you know do your
thing
i think we for me i really i really love
what we teach
because i believe when you're debt-free
and you're making good amount of money
it brings
options and you can choose to live the
life that you want to live
not the life that you have to live and
sometimes just getting rid of the debt
does that
come you don't even have to be all the
way into you know paid for house and
everything but i mean the number of
times i've taken a call here
and um you know we have a minivan
yeah that the payment is 700 on and i
could quit work if it wasn't for the
minivan
ah got rid of the minivan just now
it's gone say bye bye odyssey
goodbye see you baby
out of here i mean really i mean but we
make choices and we like feel like we're
trapped then by the debt and you can
just amputate the minivan
and get your life back yeah amputate the
tahoe baby
yeah get your life back and uh we trade
out
chunks of who we are in order to pay
payments
uh on stuff that really doesn't change
our life absolutely
yeah so way to go good choices good
thought pattern
i love it good critical thinking this is
good